This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. What do you want to be when you grow up? Nearly all of us are asked this question very early in our lives. In the mid-1920s, a young man who went by the name of Fred had a clear answer. He wanted to be a writer. He hoped to live among other writers and artists in Paris or Greenwich Village. So Fred went to college to study literature. He read voraciously and began writing short stories. But like so many writers before him and after him, Fred found literary success elusive.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你长大后想做什么？几乎我们所有人在很小的时候都被问过这个问题。20世纪20年代中期，一个叫弗雷德的年轻人对此有着清晰的答案。他想成为一名作家。他希望住在巴黎或格林威治村，和其他作家、艺术家生活在一起。于是，弗雷德上大学攻读文学。他如饥似渴地阅读，并开始写短篇小说。但是，和在他之前以及之后的许多作家一样，弗雷德发现要在文学上取得成功并非易事。
In November 1927, he read an article by H.G. Wells in the New York Times Sunday magazine. The article asked the reader to consider who had made a bigger contribution to civilization, the playwright George Bernard Shaw or the Russian neurologist and physiologist Ivan Pavlov. Fred thought about it and decided the answer was clear. It was the Russian scientist. He set aside his writing aspirations to enter a PhD program at Harvard where he trained as a psychologist.
1927年11月，他在《纽约时报》周日杂志上读到了一篇H.G.威尔斯的文章。文章让读者思考，对文明做出更大贡献的究竟是剧作家乔治·伯纳德·肖，还是俄罗斯神经学家兼生理学家伊万·巴普洛夫。弗雷德思考了一番，认为答案很明确。那就是这位俄罗斯科学家。他搁置了自己的写作梦想，进入哈佛大学攻读博士学位，在那里接受了心理学训练。
He spent the next 40 years studying human behavior instead of writing stories about it. In that time, Burruss Frederick Skinner, better known as B.F. Skinner, became one of the most influential psychologists in the world. His work has greatly shaped our modern understanding of human behavior. Not all of us become groundbreaking scientists, but nearly all of us have had the experience of traveling down one road, only to realize it is not the road for us. Today, we kick off a new series we're calling Innovation 2.0.
在接下来的40年里，他一直在研究人类行为，而不是写关于人类行为的故事。在那段时期里，伯勒斯·弗雷德里克·斯金纳，也就是更为人所知的B.F.斯金纳，成为了世界上最有影响力的心理学家之一。他的工作极大地塑造了我们对人类行为的现代理解。我们并非所有人都能成为开创性的科学家，但几乎所有人都曾有过这样的经历：沿着一条路走下去，却突然发现这条路并不适合自己。今天，我们开启一个名为“创新2.0”的新系列。
We'll explore the science of creativity and how organizations and individuals can learn to build great things. Organizations and individuals can learn to build great things. How to set goals, launch ideas, and find your sense of direction. This week on Hidden Brain. When it comes to pursuing our goals, the path seems straightforward. Think about where you want to go, map out the steps, and get going. But this approach often fails. As we proceed toward our goals, unexpected difficulties often arise, and surprises abound.
我们将探讨创造力的科学，以及组织和个人如何学习打造伟大的事物。组织和个人如何学习打造伟大的事物。如何设定目标、推出创意并找到方向感。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在追求目标的道路上，路径似乎很直截了当。想想你想去哪里，规划步骤，然后出发。但这种方法往往会失效。在我们朝着目标前进的过程中，意想不到的困难往往会出现，惊喜也层出不穷。
At the University of Virginia, Saras Saraswati studies how we plan and prepare for the future using the lens of entrepreneurship. She's interested in how we pursue goals, launch ideas, and make decisions. Saras Saraswati, welcome to Hidden Brain. Lovely to be here, Shankar. Saras, you started out as an entrepreneur, not a researcher. In the 1980s, you were living in India, in Bombay or Mumbai, as it's known today. You launched a business involving food preparation. What was this business? This was basically a dream about starting a restaurant,
在弗吉尼亚大学，萨拉斯·萨拉斯瓦蒂通过创业的视角研究我们如何规划和筹备未来。她对我们如何追求目标、推出创意以及做出决策很感兴趣。萨拉斯·萨拉斯瓦蒂，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。萨拉斯，你最初是一名企业家，而不是研究人员。20世纪80年代，你住在印度的孟买，也就是今天人们所知的孟买。你创办了一项涉及食品准备的业务。这是个什么业务？这基本上是一个关于开餐馆的梦想，
but not having any resources to, for example, to find a location or a chef or anything. So the idea here was to just work with what I already had, which is I knew how to cook. The business became a lunch service business where basically I would cook and bring food for people downtown. I see, and how did this work? You actually would make the food in the morning and then catch a train or something and go downtown to people's offices
但没有任何资源，比如找不到合适的地点、厨师或任何东西。所以这里的想法就是利用我手头已有的东西，那就是我会做饭。这项业务变成了一项午餐配送服务，基本上就是我做饭，然后把食物带给市中心的人们。我明白了，这具体是怎么运作的？你实际上是在早晨做好饭，然后坐火车什么的去市中心人们的办公室，
and deliver meals to their desks basically? Yeah, initially it started that way and then found a commercial kitchen very, very cheap through a friend who happened to have like at one of those tiny restaurant-like places and then just took a beaten down car to go deliver. And what were these interactions like when you would drop off lunch for people? You were doing this in person at the time. What kind of interactions did you have with people when you dropped off their lunch? So delivery is not just delivery. Like all entrepreneurs,
基本上是把饭菜送到他们的办公桌上？是的，一开始是这样的，后来通过一个朋友，非常非常便宜地找到了一家商业厨房——那个朋友刚好有那种微型餐馆似的地方——然后就开着一辆破旧的汽车去送货。当你给人们送午餐时，这些互动是怎样的？你当时是亲自去做的。当你给人们送午餐时，你和他们有什么样的互动？所以送货不仅仅是送货。就像所有的企业家一样，
right? You have to become a pinch hitter. You have to do everything in the business to start with. But the most important thing is sales. So I would go in and I would be always trying to get more people to sign up. So with the customers who already ordered, I mean, these were people who knew me to begin with, I would just bring in and talk about the day, I'd explain about the food. And I would of course ask them, how was it, you know, as they taste, I would actually wait for a couple of minutes. And then I would always have a follow on ask of some kind, like, can you introduce me to the people in the next floor? And then it became the next building. And I would always bring extra so that I could give it to other people. So in the early stages, it was a mixture of just keeping the current customers engaged,
对吧？你必须成为一个全能替补。一开始，你必须做业务中的所有事情。但最重要的是销售。所以我会进去，并且总是试图争取更多的人来注册。因此，对于那些已经订购的客户——我的意思是，这些一开始就认识我的人——我会顺便进去聊聊当天的近况，我会介绍一下食物。我当然会问他们，味道怎么样，你知道的，当他们品尝时，我实际上会等待几分钟。然后我总是会顺便提出某种后续要求，比如，你能把我介绍给楼下的人吗？然后就成了下一栋楼。而且我总是会多带一些，以便可以送给其他人。所以在早期阶段，这既有维持现有客户参与度的成分，
but always pushing for a few more orders. This strategy worked and the business prospered. Saras eventually had enough orders to keep her busy in the kitchen, so she hired a delivery driver. She expected profits to soar, But that is not what happened. Not at all. In fact, the business started going down.
但同时也一直在努力争取更多订单。这个策略奏效了，业务也繁荣起来。萨拉斯最终拥有了足够的订单，让她在厨房里忙个不停，于是她雇了一个送货司机。她预计利润会飙升，但事实并非如此。完全不是。事实上，业务开始走下坡路。
And you actually think... When I say business, I mean literally the number of orders, number of people ordering. Everything was... took a downward turn. And so you start wondering what's going on. Saras wanted to get to the bottom of it. So she went back into the offices where her customers worked and asked them point blank, what gives?
而你实际上认为……当我说业务时，我的意思是字面上的订单数量，订购人数。一切都……走了下坡路。所以你开始琢磨到底是怎么回事。萨拉斯想弄清真相。于是她回到客户工作的办公室，开门见山地问他们，到底怎么回事？
So it turned out that, and it was not the easiest thing, and I'm still even today a little, I blush when I talk about this. It turned out that people actually were not thinking that the food is awesome, even though some of them would say the food is awesome. It turns out that there was something about my personality and the way these conversations that we had
结果证明——这并不是最容易做到的事，甚至直到今天我多少还是有点，当我谈到这个时我会脸红。结果证明，人们其实并没有觉得这饭菜有多棒，尽管他们中有些人会说饭菜很棒。事实证明，我的性格以及我们之间的那些对话有些特别之处，
that people missed and they were ordering it partly to see me come deliver. And to this day, I don't know exactly what, but I do know that the initial success of the business was not the food per se, it was the food and delivery combo to put it mildly. And so when you changed the combo and you had somebody else deliver the food, they were still getting their lunch, but they didn't have the interaction, the effervescent interaction that they would have with you.
是人们所怀念的，他们订购部分原因是为了看我来送货。直到今天，我也不知道具体是为什么，但我确实知道，这项业务最初的成功并不是因为食物本身，往轻了说，它是食物和配送的结合体。所以当你改变了这个组合，让别人去送食物时，他们虽然还能吃到午餐，但没有了那种互动，那种与你在一起时才有的充满活力的互动。
Yeah, I wasn't thinking effervescent interaction. I was actually crushed that they didn't like my cooking. Ha ha ha ha. So at this point, you've dipped your toe into the world of entrepreneurship. You're starting to get a pretty good idea of what it takes to be successful. You eventually start another business. It's related to drinking water issues in Mumbai. Start by giving me the context. What were these water issues? Yes. So there are thousands of these apartment complexes in Mumbai, three to five stories, sometimes taller.
是的，我当时可没想过什么充满活力的互动。得知他们不喜欢我的烹饪，我其实备受打击。哈哈哈哈。所以在这个时候，你已经涉足了创业的世界。你开始对成功需要什么有了相当不错的概念。你最终又创办了另一家企业。它与孟买的饮用水问题有关。先跟我讲讲背景。这些水问题到底是什么？是的。所以孟买有成千上万个这样的小区，三到五层楼高，有时更高。
And the way water distribution works in Mumbai is basically water comes from the municipality and it fills a tank at the street level or at the bottom floor of the building. And then the apartment complexes have on their own, they have to pump up this water to the top floor or to the terrace where there is a top tank. And from that top tank, water comes into the apartments. And so somebody has to go in and turn the water pump on so that the water can be pumped up from the bottom tack to the top tank. So this was a security guard maybe who worked at the apartment whose job it was to turn on the pump and get the water to be pumped up to the roof?
孟买的水分配方式基本上是，水从市政部门来，注入街道级别或建筑物底层的储水箱。然后小区必须自己把水抽到顶楼或有一个顶部水箱的露台。从那个顶部水箱，水再流入各个公寓。所以必须有人去打开水泵，这样水才能从底部的储水箱抽到顶部的水箱。所以这可能是一个住在小区的保安，他的工作就是打开水泵，把水抽到屋顶？
Yes. And every apartment complex usually has at least one, we used to call them watchman. And because water doesn't flow 24 hours, that's the other issue you have to think about. This water comes in only at certain times of the day. So the problem is the watchmen are not really always there, right? And some of them, they're expected to be awake all night, you know, they've not woken up or they're off somewhere having a smoke or something. And you know, they are not turning the pump on at exactly the time
是的。而且每个小区通常至少有一个，我们过去称他们为看门人。因为水不是24小时供应的，这是你必须考虑的另一个问题。水只在一天中的特定时间来。所以问题是，看门人其实并不总是呆在那里，对吧？而且他们中的一些人，本该整晚保持清醒，你知道的，他们没有醒来，或者走开去抽烟什么的。你知道的，他们并没有在准确的时间打开水泵，
that you would need early in the morning, especially when people are getting ready to send their children to school or go to work or something. So a lot of apartment complexes would have to chase down these watchmen to make sure the pumps are started at the correct time. And on top of that, there was also unpredictability when the water arrived.
尤其是在清晨人们准备送孩子上学、去上班或做其他事情的时候，你特别需要水的时候。所以很多小区都不得不追着这些看门人跑，以确保水泵能在正确的时间启动。最重要的是，水什么时候来也是不可预测的。
At the time, Saras was desperate for a new business idea. Like many entrepreneurs, she knew this meant starting with a problem, find a problem that needs fixing, and then invent a solution that would be profitable. So the solution was, why do we need the watchman? We actually can automate this thing. And this is a very simple thing. You need a gadget, an electronic gadget,
当时，萨拉斯迫切需要一个新的商业点子。和许多企业家一样，她知道这意味着要从一个问题开始：找到一个需要解决的问题，然后发明一个有利可图的解决方案。所以解决方案是，为什么我们需要看门人？我们实际上可以把这东西自动化。这是一个非常简单的东西。你需要一个小玩意儿，一个电子小玩意儿，
that will just take a look at the level of water in the lower tank. And when the level has reached a particular height in the tank, it can start pumping it up. So all we need to do is to design a contraption that does that. Along with a business partner, Saras came up with the idea for a water pump controller.
它只需观察低位水箱中的水位。当水位达到水箱中的特定高度时，它就可以开始抽水。所以我们所要做的就是设计一个能做到这一点的装置。萨拉斯和一位商业伙伴一起提出了水泵控制器的想法。
She recruited electrical engineers to help design the circuitry and even spend some time assembling the circuit boards. It was a simple solution to an important problem. And so having come up with this thing, you had to find apartment complexes that are willing to install it. And you know, just started with the apartment where we lived. We told people, you know, just let's try this out, pilot it, the watchman will still stand around and we are here while we test it.
她招募了电气工程师来帮助设计电路，甚至花了一些时间自己组装电路板。这是一个针对重要问题的简单解决方案。既然想出了这个东西，你就得找到愿意安装它的公寓小区。你知道的，就从我们自己住的小区开始。我们告诉大家，你知道的，让我们试试这个，进行试点，保安还是会站在旁边，而且在我们测试的时候我们也在场。
And at least for the first couple of weeks, we made sure we were there, the watchman was there and it worked beautifully. And so you have a proof of concept, it's worked successfully in your building. You're an entrepreneur. I'm assuming the next step is, how do I get other people to use my product? How do I generate sales? Yeah, absolutely.
至少在头几个星期里，我们确保我们在场，保安也在场，而且它运行得非常完美。所以你有了概念验证，它在你们大楼里成功运行了。你是个企业家。我假设下一步就是，我如何让其他人使用我的产品？我如何产生销售？是的，绝对是。
How do you get other people? And of course, you tend to go to people you know, so you can just go to the next apartment complex and the next one. And it's not quite like that in the sense that you go talk to people and most people are like, we don't even have time to think about this. And, you know, who are you?
你如何让其他人使用？当然，你往往会去找你认识的人，所以你可以直接去下一个小区，再下一个。但事情并非完全如此，因为你去找人谈，大多数人都会觉得，我们甚至没有时间去想这个。而且，你是谁啊？
You know, it's not the easiest thing in the world, but we knew enough number of people, both on a personal front, but also through the business. So we kept on talking to enough number of people. And I think I remember maybe a half a dozen of these signed up and in each case we really worked hard to make sure it worked properly and every single time it worked beautifully. I understand sales took off pretty quickly? Yeah, as you know, as you go from one to six, you're really excited.
你知道的，这并不是世界上最容易的事，但我们在个人层面以及通过业务认识了足够多的人。所以我们不停地与足够多的人交谈。我想我记得大概有半打左右的人签约了，而且在每一种情况下，我们都付出了艰苦的努力，以确保它正常运行，并且每一次都运行得非常完美。我听说销售很快就腾飞了？是的，你知道的，当你从一个发展到六个时，你会感到非常兴奋。
And so you start building 60. It seemed like a simple solution to a very, very important problem, as I said. So we went a little bit crazy. We thought we could go from six to 60 within a month. And then we were thinking 6,000, 60,000 already. And so began to talk to investors. I mean, classic, you know, getting into the hockey stick mode here.
于是你开始着手建造60个。正如我所说，这似乎是一个非常非常重要问题的简单解决方案。所以我们有点疯狂了。我们认为我们可以在一个月内从6个发展到60个。然后我们已经在考虑6000个、60000个了。于是开始与投资者交谈。我的意思是，经典的，你知道的，进入了曲棍球棒式的增长模式。
Saras had done everything right. Find a problem and manufacture a solution, check. Get investors on board, check. Find customers, get them to buy, then find more customers, check, check check and check. Saras's controllers were selling like hotcakes and the future looked bright. But very early one morning, as Saras had just gotten out of bed, the phone rang. And basically the person on the other end begins to scream at me,
萨拉斯把一切都做对了。找到问题并制造解决方案，打勾。让投资者加入，打勾。找到客户，让他们购买，然后找到更多客户，打勾，打勾，打勾。萨拉斯的控制器卖得火热，未来一片光明。但就在一个清晨，萨拉斯刚从床上爬起来，电话铃响了。基本上，电话那头的人开始冲我大喊，
what kind of business people are you? You have caused such a big problem for us. I don't know what to do. You come over here immediately. And for a minute, I don't know who this person is. Right, so I have to ask who's speaking. So, and that person loses it when I ask his name. He says, you know,
你们算什么生意人？你们给我们惹了这么大的麻烦。我不知道该怎么办。你马上给我滚过来。有一分钟，我甚至不知道这个人是谁。对吧，所以我得问对方是谁。所以，当我问他的名字时，那个人彻底失控了。他说，你知道，
how many people have you screwed over? Eventually, Saras figured out who the man was, the secretary of a local home owners association who had purchased one of her automatic electric pump controllers. Saras left her house and rushed across town to meet him at his building. But he wasn't alone. People are already at the entrance to the building. There are people already standing around because they're waiting for me and they're already shouting at this guy who had called me, right?
你们坑了多少人？最终，萨拉斯弄清了这个男人的身份——当地一个业主协会的秘书，他购买了她的一台自动电动泵控制器。萨拉斯离开家，急忙穿过小镇，到他的大楼去见他。但他并不是一个人。大楼入口处已经有人了。已经有人站在那里了，因为他们在等我，而且他们已经在对那个打电话给我的家伙大喊大叫了，对吧？
And there were like half a dozen families who had no water that morning. And so they had come to him and they were screaming at him. So he was stressed out because there were people. There was like a mini mob there. The homeowners took one look at Saras, who at this time was in her early 20s. This was the person to whom the apartment manager had entrusted the well-being of their building. They lost it. Everybody was really mad. And not only that, seeing me infuriated people even further, right? Because they thought the guy, the secretary of the association,
那天早上有大概半打家庭没有水。所以他们来找他，并对他大喊大叫。因此他压力很大，因为有人群。那里就像一个小型的暴民。业主们看了萨拉斯一眼，当时萨拉斯刚20岁出头。这就是公寓经理将他们大楼的福祉托付给的人。他们气疯了。每个人都非常生气。不仅如此，看到我更是让人们怒火中烧，对吧？因为他们觉得那个家伙，协会的秘书，
was just nuts to even do business with me, let alone allow me to sell him something. So things got worse. After making her way through the angry mob, the secretary walked Saras to the pump room to check out the problem. She noticed it right away. A coil in the pump had burned out. Normally, when the security guard started the pump, he would fill a little cup with water to prevent overheating. The water controller Saras had installed
竟然跟我做生意，甚至还让我把东西卖给他，简直是疯了。所以事情变得更糟了。在穿过愤怒的人群后，秘书带着萨拉斯去了泵房查看问题。她一眼就注意到了。泵里的一个线圈烧坏了。通常情况下，保安启动水泵时，会在一个小杯子里装满水以防止过热。萨拉斯安装的水控制器
did not do this. And without that water, the pump burns out. I see. It cannot start on its own. And we did not even know that, and we had not considered that, right? Because none of us were big engineers. We had just worked with engineers
并没有这样做。没有了水，水泵就会烧毁。我明白了。它无法自行启动。我们甚至都不知道这一点，我们也没有考虑到这一点，对吧？因为我们都不是什么大工程师。我们只是和工程师合作
to develop the thing. And especially none of us were hydroelectric engineers or plumbers or anything like that. It was a failure. The solution into which Saras had invested so much time and energy wasn't a solution at all. In fact, it made a big problem even worse. I was just heartbroken, completely panicked,
来开发这个东西。尤其是我们当中没有人是水力工程师、水管工或类似的人。这是一个失败。萨拉斯投入了大量时间和精力的解决方案根本不是什么解决方案。事实上，它让一个大问题变得更糟了。我当时心碎欲绝，彻底陷入恐慌，
like sort of shaking, but I was like, Mia kalpa, Mia maxima kalpa. Tell me what I need to do. I will do anything. I will stay with you. I will bring buckets of water from the tank. I'll pay for people to bring the water into your house today.
有点像在发抖，但我就像是，主啊，我的大错，我的弥天大错。告诉我需要我做什么。我什么都愿意做。我会留下来陪你们。我会从水箱里一桶一桶地提水。我今天出钱让人把水送到你们家。
And I'll pay, of course, for a new pump and everything like that. So it could be, course that this was an isolated incident. Was this the end of the story? Was this the only problem you encountered with your water controllers? No, this was the beginning of a Shakespearean tragedy, right? So during this encounter, I was just there, right? I was just trying to solve the problem. And it's only later in the day after we had worked out what I needed to do to make it right that the panic hit me. That we have been installing like, you know, several dozens of these.
当然，我也会出钱买个新泵以及所有这些。这可能只是一起孤立事件。这是故事的结局吗？这是你遇到的关于水控器的唯一问题吗？不，这是一场莎士比亚式悲剧的开始，对吧？所以在这场冲突中，我就在那里，对吧？我只是在试图解决问题。直到那天晚些时候，在我们商定了我需要做些什么来弥补之后，恐慌才真正击中了我们。我们已经安装了大概，你知道的，几十个这样的东西。
And so immediately started thinking we need to go and inspect every one of them. And it turned out by the next day, I started getting more calls. By the time we went out to people, people started realizing that this was burning there and made a mistake. So by the time I got two or three more calls the next day, we were already going out to every single installation and looking for the pumps that needed the priming and telling people you cannot use this controller anymore. And so at this point now you know that the gizmo that you built has a problem. You know that there's an even bigger problem because it's actually caused damage in many of these buildings that you're going to
所以我立刻开始想，我们需要去检查每一个设备。结果证明，到了第二天，我开始接到更多的电话。当我们出去走访时，人们开始意识到这正在烧毁，并犯下了错误。所以第二天我又接到两三个电话时，我们已经赶往每一个安装现场，寻找需要引水灌注的水泵，并告诉人们你不能再使用这个控制器了。所以到了这个时候，你知道你制造的小玩意儿有问题。你知道有一个更大的问题，因为它实际上在许多这些大楼里造成了损害，你将不得不
have to fix that damage. It's a it's sort of a public relations disaster. What happens at this point? You're in your early 20s, you know, you you thought you were on the start of a hockey stick. I guess it wasn't. It wasn't and and and remember this is why I said it's like a tragedy because you have the customers who actually suffered the problem and they're not happy. And remember, we've been talking with a couple of investors in the meanwhile, let me tell you, they were not happy. It was just one call after another. It's like doing some kind of firefighting. So all stakeholders, my family was like really
修复这些损害。这有点像一场公关灾难。这个时候会发生什么？你二十出头，你知道的，你以为你正处于曲棍球棒式增长的起点。我猜并不是。确实不是，而且——记住，这就是为什么我说这就像一场悲剧，因为你有遭受了问题的客户，他们很不高兴。而且记住，与此同时我们一直在和几个投资者交谈，我告诉你，他们可一点都不高兴。这简直就是一个接一个的电话。就像是在进行某种消防灭火。所以所有的利益相关者，我的家里人真的
pissed off at me, right? Because they had been trying to say for a while, don't go into business and we are not from a business community, right? We are lower middle class. You are so smart. You're getting all these job offers. Just take a job. Why are you throwing your life away? I mean, so every minute of the day was just this confrontation and then end the day as a puzzle. All of us, even those of us who are not entrepreneurs, make plans for the future. But as Saras discovered with her two ventures, once you make a plan, there's stuff you don't know about.
生我的气，对吧？因为他们之前一直试图说，不要去做生意，我们不是来自商业社区，对吧？我们是下中产阶级。你这么聪明。你得到了所有这些工作机会。随便找个工作吧。你为什么要把自己的人生扔掉？我的意思是，所以一天的每一分钟都只是这种对抗，然后带着一个谜题结束这一天。我们所有人，甚至是我们这些不是企业家的人，都在为未来做计划。但正如萨拉斯在她的两次创业中所发现的那样，一旦你制定了计划，就会有你不知道的事情。
You can learn new things to address this problem. But there is also stuff you don't know that you don't know. And it's very hard to prepare for this. When we come back, where Saras went wrong and what research shows is the most effective way to pursue our ambitions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Even if you don't consider yourself an entrepreneur, chances are you have ideas you'd like to see come to life. Maybe it's launching a creative project or starting a side hustle. Maybe you'd
你可以学习新的东西来解决这个问题。但也有你不知道自己不知道的事情。而且很难对此做好准备。当我们回来时，萨拉斯哪里做错了，以及研究表明追求我们雄心的最有效方法是什么。你在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。即使你不认为自己是个企业家，你很可能也有想要实现的创意。也许是发起一个创意项目，或者开始一份副业。也许你
like to start an organization in your community. Maybe your goals are personal. You want to get in shape or you want to have successful relationships. At the University of Virginia's Darden School of Business, Saras Saraswati says there are some common mistakes we make when it comes to getting our plans off the ground. Saras, as you were launching your water pump controller business, getting our plans off the ground. Saras, as you were launching your water pump controller business,
想在你的社区里创办一个组织。也许你的目标是个人方面的。你想保持身材，或者你想建立成功的人际关系。在弗吉尼亚大学达顿商学院，萨拉斯·萨拉斯瓦蒂表示，当我们将计划付诸实践时，我们会犯一些常见的错误。萨拉斯，在你推出水泵控制器业务的过程中，将我们的计划付诸实践。萨拉斯，在你推出水泵控制器业务的过程中，
you noticed there was a problem. Many apartment buildings in Mumbai were running out of water because the pump was not working properly or the security guard had not turned on the pump. I feel you were doing exactly what young entrepreneurs are often taught to do, find a problem in the world, and then devise a profitable solution.
你发现了一个问题。孟买的许多公寓楼因为水泵工作不正常或保安没有打开水泵而面临断水。我觉得你当时做的正是年轻企业家经常被教导要去做的事情：在世界上找到一个问题，然后设计出一个有利可图的解决方案。
Can you talk about how common this advice is and why the advice might not be right? That's a great and interesting question. When I went through my business, people were telling us things like, you know, here's the story of an entrepreneur and the way you do it is you have to solve a big problem or, but also in a profitable way, right? And so the first problem is you can see the problem and you can solve the problem like with my pump controller, but then it's not clear that it is going to be profitable as a business, right? The unit of the product may be profitable.
你能谈谈这个建议有多普遍，以及为什么这个建议可能并不正确吗？这是一个伟大而有趣的问题。当我经历我的创业过程时，人们会告诉我们一些事情，比如，这是一个企业家的故事，你这样做的方法是你必须解决一个大问题，或者，也要以一种有利可图的方式，对吧？所以第一个问题是，你可以看到问题，并且你可以解决问题——就像我的水泵控制器一样，但随后并不清楚它作为一项业务是否能够盈利，对吧？该产品的单件可能是盈利的。
And then you go into this fantasy. Okay, if I can go from six to 60 to 6,000, and then you start thinking how many buildings are there? And so you go into that and then you don't realize that profitability does not work that way. That's one issue with it. The second issue with it is, and this one I had to learn the hard way, which is a lot of businesses that get started are not necessarily solving a problem out there. It's really much more about things like competence.
然后你就会陷入这种幻想中。好吧，如果我能从6个发展到60个再到6000个，然后你开始思考有多少栋楼？于是你陷入了那种状态，然后你没有意识到盈利能力并不是那样运作的。这是其中的一个问题。第二个问题是——这一点我不得不通过惨痛的教训来吸取——许多创业的企业不一定是在解决外面的某个问题。它其实更多地关乎能力之类的事情。
What is it that you know how to do? And then how can you create more value with that? But yes, in the beginning, I was totally bought into this idea that every business begins with a problem. It's also the case that at some level, you know, you know that there's a problem because you know the water pumps are not pumping the water up.
你知道自己会做什么？然后你如何用它创造更多的价值？但是是的，一开始，我完全相信了“每个企业都始于一个问题”这种想法。某种程度上也是如此，你知道的，你知道有问题，因为你知道水泵没有把水抽上来。
And so you say, okay, there's a solution to that. But you didn't know about the priming cup that was necessary to prevent the pumps from burning out. So there was in fact a deeper problem that was hidden behind the first problem. You didn't even know it existed until it blew up in your face. Yeah, absolutely. And not only did I not know that, look at why I did not know that, right?
所以你说，好吧，这有一个解决方案。但你不知道防止水泵烧毁所需的引水杯。所以事实上，隐藏在第一个问题背后还有一个更深层次的问题。在它当头棒喝之前，你甚至不知道它的存在。是的，绝对是。不仅我不知道这一点，看看我为什么不知道，对吧？
It's because my competence is not in building pumps or improving pumps or innovating on pumps or even in electronics. So this is exactly what an entrepreneur does, like finds a problem and then figures out a way to solve it, irrespective of whether you have the resources or you have the knowledge or whatever. When you were manufacturing these water pump controllers, you hired an electrician who came in as a consultant, but you told me that you also took it upon yourself to learn how to build these electronic circuit boards. And on the surface, this seems like the right thing to do. It seems almost noble that you wanted to learn
那是因为我的能力不在于制造水泵、改进水泵、在水泵上进行创新，甚至不在于电子学。所以这正是一个企业家所做的，找到一个问题然后想办法解决它，不管你是否有资源、是否有知识等等。当你制造这些水泵控制器时，你雇了一位作为顾问的电工，但你告诉我，你还承担起了学习如何构建这些电子电路板的任务。表面上看，这似乎是正确的事情。你想要学习
how to build these things yourself. But in hindsight, you are getting in well over your head, Saras. Oh, absolutely. And plus there was nothing noble about it, right? It's a cost issue, Shankar. And also the reality of a lot of very small ventures or startup companies, right?
如何自己构建这些东西，这似乎甚至有点崇高。但事后看来，萨拉斯，你真的是自不量力了。哦，绝对是的。而且这没有什么崇高可言，对吧？这是一个成本问题，尚卡尔。这也是许多非常小的风险企业或初创公司的现实，对吧？
And when you learn it yourself, it's easier to have employees and people to actually do it for you because you have to supervise them. And they have even less knowledge than you have. And you actually have very little knowledge than you have. And you actually have very little knowledge compared to the expert. So that's just common in many, many ventures. And I, again, experienced it in the school of hard knocks. So another mistake we make is that we fail to notice, you know, signals of problems that are
当你自己学会了，更容易让员工和人们实际为你去做，因为你必须监督他们。而且他们的知识甚至比你还要少。而你实际上的知识与专家相比其实非常少。所以这在许许多多的企业中是很常见的。而我，再次在碰壁中体验到了这一点。所以我们犯的另一个错误是，我们没有注意到，你知道的，正在出现的
coming in. At a much larger scale, this also affects big companies. I'm thinking about the experience of Blockbuster as streaming television was starting to arise. Can you tell me the story of what happened with Blockbuster and the rise of Netflix, Saras? That is a lovely question, and it is also something that we have looked at in research. So you think once you have solved a problem, you think that you're riding a wave and that wave is going to go on for a long, long time. Then along comes several other things
问题的信号。在更大的规模上，这也影响着大公司。我想到了流媒体电视开始兴起时百视达的经历。萨拉斯，你能给我讲讲百视达发生的事情以及奈飞的崛起吗？这是一个很好的问题，这也是我们在研究中探讨过的内容。所以你认为一旦你解决了问题，你就会乘风破浪，而且这股浪潮会持续很长时间。然后紧接着又发生了其他几件事情，
that are also going on, but because your business is going so well, right? You look at ideas and you start thinking about this will not work, that's a stupid idea. That is too small a thing. And that's what happened with Netflix, right? So with Blockbuster, you are doing so well. They had like 9,000 stores or something like this,
这些事情也在进行中，但因为你的业务进展得非常顺利，对吧？你看待各种创意，并开始认为这不会工作，那是愚蠢的主意。那东西太小了。这就是奈飞发生的事情，对吧？所以对百视达来说，你们当时做得太好了。他们拥有大约9000家门店或类似规模的东西，
if I remember, around the time that they started noticing, A, there were other businesses that started, Redbox, for example, started saying there's no need to pay this upfront fee that you have to pay with Blockbusters, right? And Netflix started doing the same thing. So they just thought these are just kind of young Turk people who are trying to compete because we have such a great business and such a great market. They're just trying to kind of nip around our heels, right? That's the attitude.
如果我没记错的话，大约在他们开始注意到的时候：A，有其他企业开始出现，例如红盒（Redbox），开始说没有必要支付你必须在百视达支付的那种前期费用，对吧？奈飞也开始做同样的事情。所以他们只是认为这些只是一些试图竞争的年轻后生，因为我们有这么棒的业务和这么棒的市场。他们只是试图在我们的脚后跟旁边咬一口，对吧？这就是这种态度。
And you think that that's going nowhere. And that is the kind of thing, because you're projecting this wave is going to last for a very long time. But also Blockbuster was levered up too much, right? They had debt on their books. They were accumulating debt in their fast growth. It's this perfect storm that gets created when you start projecting into the future,
而且你认为那根本行不通。这就是那种情况，因为你预测这股浪潮会持续很长很长时间。但百视达也过度杠杆化了，对吧？他们的账面上有债务。他们在快速增长中不断累积债务。当你开始对未来进行预测时，就会产生这种完美的风暴，
but they also start placing big bets on that projection. Because of course, if things are unpredictable and you're placing big bets on what's going to happen, when one of the things in the future that you think is going to happen doesn't happen, then you might be up the creek without a paddle, as they say. It's not only that your projections are wrong, but when you're riding the wave, you do not see that the projection can be wrong at all. It's also sort of like health and life, right? In your 30s, you think you're immortal. In your 40s and 50s, you are in such denial that you do everything to prove that you're immortal, right? Fitness, whatever.
但他们也对这种预测下了重注。因为当然，如果事情是不可预测的，而你对将要发生的事情下了重注，当未来你认为会发生的事情之一没有发生时，正如他们所说，你可能就会陷入没有双桨的小船中，进退维谷。不仅你的预测是错的，而且当你乘风破浪时，你根本看不到预测可能是错的。这也有点像健康和生活，对吧？在你30多岁时，你觉得自己是不朽的。在你40多岁和50多岁时，你处于如此强烈的否认状态，以至于你做每件事来证明自己是不朽的，对吧？健身什么的。
And then one day something happens and you're confronted, right? Fitness, whatever. And then one day something happens and you're confronted with mortality. I mean, all of us do this all the time. And then in organizations that are doing very well and making a lot of money, there's also this group think that sets in, right? Everybody wants to believe it. Everybody sort of reinforces each other's denial
然后有一天发生了某些事情，你面对现实了，对吧？健身什么的。然后有一天发生了某些事情，你不得不面对终将一死的现实。我的意思是，我们所有人都一直在这样做。然后，在那些经营得很好且赚了很多钱的组织中，也会出现这种群体思维，对吧？每个人都想相信这一点。每个人都在某种程度上强化彼此对这些事情的否认，
of these things. And so you just take things for granted. We can see from the blockbuster story that another pitfall even the smartest entrepreneurs fall into is not knowing when to change course. So where do they go wrong? is not knowing when to change course. So where do they go wrong? You have to think about it. The first step you have to do is to think about the decisions that you're making. Even if you're Coca-Cola and you know exactly how many you're going to sell, and probably your predictions are 100% correct, you still have to think about all the positive opportunities out there that you might miss by not investing in something new. So that is this fallacy that your own, whatever
于是你把事情视为理所当然。从百视达的故事中我们可以看出，即使是最聪明的企业家也会陷入的另一个陷阱，就是不知道何时改变方向。那么他们哪里做错了？就是不知道何时改变方向。那么他们哪里做错了？你必须考虑这一点。你必须采取的第一步是思考你正在做出的决策。即使你是可口可乐，并且你确切知道你要卖出多少瓶，而且可能你的预测是100%正确的，你仍然必须考虑所有那些你可能因为没有投资新事物而错过的积极机会。所以这就是那种谬误：你自己的、无论
you think you're doing well is going to continue, but it's also missing out on other things that could be happening that you could be a part of. So one of the ways you think about this problem is to think about the decisions that you're making, all the positive opportunities out there that you might miss by not investing in something new. This is why, again, when you go to Blockbuster, it's not just that you get it wrong, right? We can all get it wrong, especially in a world of fast change, but are there other ways of building this future without having to lever up, without having to ignore competition? Is that a way, for example,
你认为自己做得好的事情会继续下去，但这也是错失了其他可能正在发生的、你可以成为其中一部分的事情。所以思考这个问题的方法之一是思考你正在做出的决策，思考所有那些你可能因为没有投资新事物而错过的积极机会。这就是为什么，再次回到百视达，不仅是你弄错了，对吧？我们都会弄错，尤其是在一个瞬息万变的时代，但是有没有其他方法来构建这个未来，而不必过度杠杆化，不必忽视竞争？例如，有没有一种方法，
that I can partner with competition? Maybe I can even invest in what will become my competition in the future. I mean, there are many, many, many other techniques and strategies that we could consider, but the idea that you can always be wrong, that is really the thing that we want to be emphasizing here. I understand you once ran a study that looked at novice
我可以与竞争对手合作？也许我甚至可以投资那些未来会成为我竞争对手的东西？我的意思是，还有许许多多我们可以考虑的技术和策略，但“你可能总是错的”这一理念，确实是我们在这里想要强调的重点。据我所了解，你曾经做过一项研究，研究了新手
versus expert entrepreneurs and how they make decisions about the future. What did you find that novice entrepreneurs typically do when it comes to looking for data, Saras? The study was really interesting in separating out novices and experts. And so novices either consist of people who have never started a company, but are thinking of starting one, or people who have started their very first company, but they're in their very early stages, first couple of years, or things like that. So most novice entrepreneurs are all over the place. The first thing that we find in the thing is they are just looking for information. So if they come into like an MBA program or a business school program or they take some courses, people teach them some things, right? But then they over learn from it,
与专家企业家在如何就未来做出决策方面的区别。萨拉斯，你发现在寻找数据时，新手企业家通常会做什么？这项研究在区分新手和专家方面非常有趣。因此，新手要么由从未创办过公司但正考虑创办的人组成，要么由创办了第一家公司但处于非常早期阶段（前几年左右）的人组成。所以大多数新手企业家都毫无章法。我们在研究中发现的第一件事是，他们只是在寻找信息。所以如果他们进入像MBA项目或商学院项目，或者他们修了一些课程，人们会教他们一些东西，对吧？但随后他们会对此过度学习，
right? So they really start believing that if you go out and ask, say, survey 100 people and 75 people loved your product, or they filled out a survey saying they loved it, that means that 75% of all the people in that demographic or in that segment is going to buy your product or something like that, right? So they think that the data actually tells you what will happen in the future. So in general, novices will, you know, sort of follow all these weird things,
对吧？所以他们真的开始相信，如果你出去问，比方说调查100个人，其中75个人喜欢你的产吕，或者他们填写的调查问卷显示他们喜欢它，这就意味着该人口统计数据或该细分市场中所有人的75%都会买你的产品或类似的东西，对吧？所以他们认为数据实际上会告诉你未来会发生什么。因此总的来说，新手会，你知道的，盲目追随所有这些奇怪的事情，
or they'll have a favorite entrepreneur and, you know, they will say, Elon Musk does it this way, so I will do the same thing or something like that. And then they go out and talk to a bunch of people and then they over generalize from their data that they have collected. Now, when you look at the expert entrepreneurs, a lot of them then look at the data and really not take the data at face value. In fact, one expert entrepreneur I studied said it beautifully, he said, you know what, data about the past is fine, right? When somebody starts giving me data about what they will do in the future, I just ignore
或者他们会有一个崇拜的企业家，你知道的，他们会说，埃隆·马斯克就是这么做的，所以我也要这样做之类的。然后他们出去和一群人交谈，接着就从他们收集的数据中过度概括。现在，当你观察专家企业家时，他们中的许多人看待数据时，真的不会把数据当成理所当然的面值。事实上，我研究过的一位专家企业家说得太好了，他说，你知道吗，关于过去的数据是可以的，对吧？当有人开始给我关于他们未来会做什么的数据时，我直接忽略它，
it because I don't believe in predicting the future. And so their attitudes towards data are very, very different. When we come back, what successful entrepreneurs do as they make decisions? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the late 1990s,
因为我不相信预测未来。因此，他们对待数据的态度非常非常不同。当我们回来时，成功的企业家在做决策时会做什么？你在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在20世纪90年代末，
Sara Saraswati was a PhD student at Carnegie Mellon University in Pittsburgh. She was working with Herb Simon, the economist who won a Nobel Prize in 1978, for his work on decision-making and problem-solving to answer the question, how do the world's most successful entrepreneurs go about solving problems and pursuing their goals? Sara, in 1997 you took a road trip to find and interview successful entrepreneurs. Can you describe this trip for me? Where did you go?
萨拉·萨拉斯瓦蒂是匹兹堡卡耐基梅隆大学的博士生。她与赫伯特·西蒙合作——这位经济学家曾因其在决策和问题解决方面的工作而荣获1978年诺贝尔奖——旨在回答这个问题：世界上最成功的企业家是如何着手解决问题和追求目标的？萨拉，1997年你进行了一次公路旅行，去寻找并采访成功的企业家。你能为我描述一下这次旅行吗？你去了哪里？
Who did you meet? So the study was about expert entrepreneurs. They were looking for people who had 10, 15 years immersive full-time experience, starting and running multiple ventures, including successes and failures. And then taken at least one company public, but the main thing was these are people who have been through every experience that entrepreneurship can offer,
你遇到了谁？所以这项研究是关于专家型企业家的。他们寻找的是拥有10到15年沉浸式全职经验的人，这些人曾创办并运营过多项企业，经历过成功与失败。并且至少有一家公司成功上市，但最重要的是，这些人经历了创业所能提供的各种体验，
including successes and failures. The road trip was informed by research that Herb Simon and his colleagues had done some years earlier. They were trying to build a computer program capable of mimicking human problem solving. To do this, they recruited a handful of expert problem solvers, chess grandmasters. And the method they invented was called the Think Allowed Verbal Protocol. The idea is you go to an expert in the field, like a chess grandmaster, and you ask them
包括成功与失败。这次公路旅行受到了赫伯特·西蒙和他的同事们几年前所做研究的启发。他们试图构建一个能够模仿人类问题解决能力的计算机程序。为了做到这一点，他们招募了少数几位专家级问题解决者——国际象棋特级大师。他们发明的方法被称为“有声思维言语协议”。这个想法是，你去找该领域的专家，比如国际象棋特级大师，然后问他们
to play chess. So you observe them while they're playing chess, but you do one additional thing. You tell them you have to talk continuously as you're thinking about your next move. So you cannot just make a move. So they would put two players in separate rooms so they don't know what the other person is thinking. But each player had to think aloud continuously in deciding which move to make. So that's how they could write the computer programs. So they were looking at which moves are they considering and rejecting and which moves, and then how do they actually come to the final decision of which move to make? And they got that data. And I used that method to study expert entrepreneurs.
来下棋。所以你在一旁观察他们下棋，但你多做了一件事。你告诉他们，在思考下一步棋时必须持续说话。所以你们不能只是默默落子。因此，他们会把两名选手安排在不同的房间里，这样他们就不知道对方在想什么。但每个棋手在决定走哪一步时，都必须持续大声说出他们的想法。这就是他们编写计算机程序的方法。因此，他们观察的是他们在考虑和拒绝哪些走法，以及他们究竟是如何对下一步棋做出最终决定的？他们收集到了这些数据。我就是用这种方法来研究专业创业者的。
The common wisdom at the time was that the chess grandmasters could simply see further ahead than beginners. If novices were able to see two moves ahead, the grandmasters could see 10 moves ahead, the grandmasters could see 10 moves ahead or 20. And it turned out that what really good chess players are very good at is they have a much bigger data bank inside their heads because they've played thousands of games, right, especially if they played professionally. So their brain becomes very good at looking at the chessboard. When you and I look at a chessboard, if we are asked to recreate a chessboard after looking at it for like 30 seconds, we will not be able to get even seven of the pieces right, right?
当时普遍的看法是，国际象棋特级大师只是比新手能看更远。如果新手能看两步，特级大师就能看十步，或者二十步。事实证明，真正厉害的棋手之所以擅长此道，是因为他们脑海中拥有更大的数据库，因为他们下过成千上万局棋，对吧，特别是如果他们是以职业身份下棋的话。所以他们的大脑非常擅长观察棋盘。当你我和我看着一个棋盘时，如果有人要求我们在看它大约30秒钟后将其复原，我们甚至连七个棋子都摆不对，对吧？
But whereas the really good chess players can recreate it perfectly because they have like names for entire combinations of positions on a board. It's pattern recognition taken to the nth degree when you are an expert in something. And notice that this is not only experience, right? Just playing chess for 40 years is not going to make you a grandmaster. You have to play, but you also have to think and learn and you have this thing called deliberate practice.
然而，真正优秀的棋手却能完美地复原它，因为他们甚至为棋盘上各种位置的组合起了名字。当你成为某一领域的专家时，这就是发挥到极致的模式识别。请注意，这不仅仅是经验，对吧？仅仅下40年的棋并不能让你成为特级大师。你必须下棋，但也必须思考和学习，并且你要经历一种叫做刻意练习的东西。
You have to push yourself to the next level. So it's a particular, you have to learn from your experience in a particular way, and that's how you become an expert chess player or an expert at anything. Saras wondered, do expert entrepreneurs work the same way? Using Herb Simon's method, Saras asked the entrepreneurs in her study to solve a problem out loud. These weren't chess moves, but business-related problems that she asked them to work through.
你必须把自己推向下一个水平。所以这是一种特殊的要求，你必须以特定方式从经验中学习，这就是你如何成为一名国际象棋专家或任何领域的专家。萨拉斯不禁好奇，专业创业者也是这样工作的吗？萨拉斯运用赫伯特·西蒙的方法，要求她研究中的创业者大声说出他们解决问题的方法。这些不是下棋的步骤，而是她要求他们着手解决的商业相关问题。
As they talked through their solutions, Saras noticed that there were five concrete habits that distinguished how these experts approach problems differently from novice entrepreneurs. The first is something Saras calls, bird in hand. So normally we think we have to start with a goal of some kind, right? Or an effect that we want to create in the world. So the goal could be to solve a problem. The goal could be I want to make a lot of money. Like in my case, I want to build a restaurant and it'd be nice to have a location and a chef and enormous amounts of money to do decor and music, but they don't have anything. So I am faced with two possibilities.
在他们一边交谈一边阐述解决方案时，萨拉斯注意到有五个具体的习惯，区分了这些专家和新手创业者对待问题方式的不同。第一点是萨拉斯称之为“手头之鸟”的概念。通常我们认为我们必须从某种目标开始，对吧？或者从我们想要在这个世界上创造某种影响开始。所以目标可能是解决一个问题。目标也可能是我想赚大钱。就像我的情况，我想开一家餐馆，如果能有一个好地段、一个厨师，还有巨额资金来搞装修和音乐，那就太好了，但我现在什么都没有。所以我面临两种可能性。
One is I can go and come up with a plan. I can write down my visualization of my restaurant, and I can go and try to convince somebody to give me the money, right? So I go investment route. I start with an effect I want to create, a goal. And now I'm beginning to think, what are all the means, all the resources that I need, and I start chasing the resources. The expert entrepreneurs did the opposite.
一种是我可以去制定一个计划。我可以写下我开餐馆的构想，然后去试着说服某人把钱借给我，对吧？所以我走的是投资路线。我从我想要创造的影响、一个目标开始。现在我开始思考，我需要的所有方法和资源是什么，然后我开始追逐这些资源。但专业创业者的做法恰恰相反。
They did not start with a goal. They did not start with some big opportunity or some problem or something. They literally said, what do I have within my control? Who am I? What do I know? Whom do I know? So even if I want to start a retail business, you know, even if I have some kind of general goal or I want to make a lot of money, this is not a very clear goal, right?
他们不是从一个目标开始的。他们不是从什么宏大的机会、问题或其他事情开始的。他们直截了当地说：我有什么是在我控制范围之内的？我是谁？我知道什么？我认识谁？所以，即使我想开一家零售店，你知道的，即使我有某种宏观的目标，或者我想赚大钱，但这并不是一个非常清晰的目标，对吧？
Even if I have a goal, so whether I have a goal or not, I'm actually starting with me. I'm not starting with the goal. I'm literally asking myself, who am I? What do I know? Whom do I know, whom do I know? That is my bird in hand. I understand that you teach this idea in your classes pointing to Airbnb as an example. Airbnb of course allows people to offer their homes to others for short-term rentals. How did this business come about in the first place, Saras?
即使我有一个目标，所以不管我有没有目标，我其实都是从“我”开始的。我不是从目标开始的。我实际上是在问自己：我是谁？我知道什么？我认识谁，我认识谁？这就是我手头之鸟。我明白你在课堂上会传授这个理念，并以Airbnb作为例子。Airbnb当然是让人把自己的房屋租给别人做短期住宿。萨拉斯，这个生意最初是怎么来的？
So today, if you took a course in entrepreneurship, people would tell you, you have to come up with a great idea for a business, right? Or solve a problem of some kind. Now let's go look at what Brian Chesky and Joe Gebbia, the co-founders of Airbnb, what was the idea they came up with and how and why did they come up with it?
所以今天，如果你去上一门创业课，人们会告诉你，你必须想出一个很棒的商业点子，对吧？或者解决某种问题。现在让我们来看看Airbnb的联合创始人布莱恩·切斯基和乔·杰比亚，他们想出了什么点子，他们又是如何以及为什么想出这个点子的？
When you ask that question, you find that these are young people, they are in San Francisco, they have this apartment, and they're thinking about how do we pay rent because it's becoming increasingly difficult to meet their rent obligations. And it turns out that the apartment had an extra bedroom that they were not using
当你问这个问题时，你会发现这是一群年轻人，他们在旧金山，他们租了这套公寓，他们正在考虑怎么付房租，因为要履行付房租的义务变得越来越困难。事实证明，这套公寓里有一个他们没用过的多余卧室。
and they had an air mattress in that bedroom. And in trying to think how can we make a little bit of money so we can sustain ourselves and pay rent in San Francisco, they just look at this air mattress and say, maybe you know what somebody would pay to come and use our spare bedroom and the air mattress. And why don't we just put up a website
那间卧室里还有一个充气床垫。为了想想怎么能赚点小钱来维持生计并支付旧金山的房租，他们看着这个充气床垫说，也许你知道的，会有人付钱来用我们的备用卧室和充气床垫。为什么我们不做一个网站
and see if anybody shows up? And that's how they get the idea. They're not thinking at that time that there's going to be this multi-billion dollar business or anything like that. They were trying to solve their own problem in some ways and they did what they knew how to do. And it turns out to be a business idea. They do know how to take it to the next level, just the next step of making a professional website. And that's what they had kind of day one in the Airbnb story.
看看有没有人来呢？这就是他们灵感的来源。当时他们并没有想过要搞一个价值几十亿美元的商业帝国之类的事情。他们在某种程度上只是想解决自己的问题，并且他们做了自己知道该怎么做的事。结果这就成了一个商业点子。他们确实知道如何把它推向下一个阶段，也就是制作一个专业网站的下一步。这就是Airbnb故事第一天的情形。
And you can see it's all like bird in hand. They're in San Francisco. They already have the apartment. They have this spare bedroom. They have the air mattress. And they have the problem, right? Which is how do I pay my own rent? So there's a second habit that you found among successful entrepreneurship, and it's something you call the principle of affordable losses. What does this mean, Saras? So when you start Shankar with the bird in hand, right, you immediately have to also think about, are you going to do with things that are already within their control, your bird in hand, or are you going to go out and raise some money or raise some resources on things that
你可以看到，这一切都像“手头之鸟”。他们在旧金山。他们已经有了公寓。他们有这个多余的卧室。他们有充气床垫。他们还有一个问题，对吧？那就是我怎么付房租？你发现成功创业者身上有第二个习惯，你称之为“承受得起损失的原则”。萨拉斯，这是什么意思？所以，尚卡尔，当你从手头之鸟开始时，对吧，你必须立刻思考：你是要用那些已经在你控制范围内的东西（也就是你的手头之鸟），还是打算出去筹集一些资金或资源去买那些
you don't have? The moment you run out to try and raise some resources, people ask you for projections. If you have to get somebody to invest, you have to make some financial projections and tell them how much money they will make and things like that. And people start predicting future cash flows and what the risks may be. And they start calculating how much money they will make and things like that. And people start predicting future cash flows and what the risks may be. And they start calculating how much money people can make. They start focusing on expected return. When you look at the expert entrepreneurs, again, they do the inverse of this. They just simply ask, what can I do for affordable loss. So in the case of Airbnb for example, it costs them nothing because they already have the extra bedroom and the air mattress, right? So when you combine burden hand with affordable loss, it also gives you control over the downside
你没有的东西？你一旦跑出去试图筹集资源，人们就会向你索要预测数据。如果你必须让别人投资，你就必须做出一些财务预测，告诉他们能赚多少钱之类的事情。人们开始预测未来的现金流以及可能存在的风险。他们开始计算人们能赚多少钱。他们开始关注预期回报。而当你观察那些专业创业者时，他们再次做了相反的事情。他们只是简单地问：为了我能承受得起的损失，我能做些什么。以Airbnb为例，这根本不花他们什么钱，因为他们已经有了多余的卧室和充气床垫，对吧？所以，当你把手头之鸟和承受得起的损失结合起来时，它还能让你控制住下行风险。
because if the thing fails you're going to lose nothing more than you can afford to lose. When the founders of Airbnb, Brian Chesky and Joe Gebbia, realized they had a great business idea on their hands, they did something else that was interesting. They recruited a friend to help them with the technological side of the business. Sara says this is another example of what expert entrepreneurs do. They find the right people to help them level up.
因为如果事情失败了，你损失的不会超过你能承受的范围。当Airbnb的创始人布莱恩·切斯基和乔·杰比亚意识到他们手头有一个绝佳的商业点子时，他们还做了一件很有趣的事。他们招募了一个朋友来帮他们处理业务的技术方面。萨拉斯说，这是专业创业者所作所为的又一个例子。他们找到合适的人来帮助自己升级。
She calls this the crazy quilt principle. So the crazy quilt principle is the idea that you are going to work with whoever wants to work with you, but only if they put skin in the game. So if you go back to the affordable loss principles, one way to say is I need X amount of dollars to do X, Y, and Z. But when you break down the things that you're going to spend that investment on, 80%, 90% of all of those will be going to pay other people.
她把这叫做“疯狂拼布原则”。所以疯狂拼布原则的意思是，你将和任何想与你合作的人共事，但前提是他们必须有切身的利益绑定。如果你回看承受得起损失的原则，一种说法是我需要X数量的资金来做X、Y和Z。但当你把你要把这笔投资花在上面的事情进行细分时，所有这些当中的80%、90%其实都是用来付给别人的。
You want to hire somebody to do your sales, you want to hire a CTO or you are going to pay somebody to design your brand or whatever it may be. And so the way to do it is to go out and talk to people and convince them to come do this with you and not charge you any money upfront. But that commitment can be affordable loss for them. And a kick-ass example of that is actually Richard Branson.
你想雇人来做销售，你想雇一个首席技术官，或者你要付钱让人家来设计你的品牌，无论那是什么。所以这样做的办法就是走出去跟别人谈，说服他们和你一起来做这件事，并且不预先支付他们任何金钱。但这种承诺对他们来说可以是承受得起的损失。而这方面一个绝佳的例子其实是理查德·布兰森。
At that time, he was not so rich at Branson. He was not this hugely successful entrepreneur. But he did, he was young, he had started Virgin Records and Virgin Records had been successful. And suddenly he travels a lot and he thinks, I have a better idea, a cooler idea for a better airline and how do I start this? He could have gone and raised money. Everybody tells him this is a high investment, investment intensive kind of business. He basically calls up Boeing and he says, hey, you know, somewhere, you know, you must have some planes hanging around, not making money for you.
当时，布兰森并没有那么富有。他当时还不是那个极其成功的创业者。但他年轻，他创立了维珍唱片，而且维珍唱片取得了成功。突然间，他经常旅行，他想，我有一个更好的点子，关于一家更好的航空公司的更酷的点子，我该怎么开始呢？他本可以去筹集资金。每个人都告诉他这是一个高投资、重资本的行业。他基本上给波音公司打电话说：“嘿，你知道吗，在某个地方，你们一定有一些闲置的、不为你们赚钱的飞机。”
Can you let me have them for a year or two? Because I have this cool idea for an airline. And you know, if it doesn't work out, I'll bring the planes back to you in the best possible condition I can. If it works out, let's talk a deal. So for Boeing though, if you think about it, to try something new and innovative, invest in it early on, it's not that expensive to lease a few planes is not that expensive. And it makes it completely affordable loss for Richard Branson's to go off and build
“能借给我用一两年吗？因为我对航空公司有个很酷的点子。你知道的，如果行不通，我会以我能达到的最好状态把飞机还给你们。如果行得通，我们再来谈一笔交易。”所以对波音公司来说，如果你仔细想想，尝试一些新的创新事物，在早期进行投资，租赁几架飞机的成本其实并不算太高。这使得理查德·布兰森去建立
an airline. So it's affordable loss on both sides. There's example after example after example of this kind. There are lots of people in manufacturing, for example, you come up with a new idea for a nutrition bar, you can go to a co-packer and you can work with them. And for them, it doesn't cost much so long as you allow them to run the production during their downtime or something like that, so it becomes an affordable loss for them.
一家航空公司的成本对他来说是完全承受得起的。所以这对双方来说都是可以承受得起的损失。这种例子比比皆是。例如，制造行业里有很多这样的人，你产生了一个关于营养棒的新想法，你可以去找一个代工厂与他们合作。对他们来说，这花不了多少钱，只要你允许他们在设备闲置期间进行生产，或者做类似的事情，这就成了他们可以承受的损失。
They will make you a minimum amount of quantity that you can get on the shelves of different stores and try it out. So you don't have to do a prototype of a nutrition bar. You can do a full production run for pretty close to nothing. Being a successful entrepreneur doesn't mean you'll never fail. But Sarah says that when expert entrepreneurs fail, they are better at turning lemons into lemonade. So, the lemonade principle is the idea that when you build ventures effectually, right,
他们会为你生产出最低数量的产品，你可以把它们摆上不同商店的货架去试水。所以你不需要去做营养棒的原型。你可以花几乎可以说是零成本的代价进行一次完整的生产。成为一名成功的创业者并不意味着你永远不会失败。但萨拉斯说，当专业创业者失败时，他们更擅长把烂牌打成王牌（把柠檬变成柠檬汁）。所以，“柠檬汁原则”的意思是，当你以效果逻辑建立企业时，对吧，
without predicting the future, always doing things within your control, the fact is there are lots of things outside your control and some of them does hit you. So the world outside hits you with lemons. And so the idea is you have to also get very good at dealing with unexpected surprises and then turn even negative surprises into opportunities. The iconic case is 3M, and they're always creating new products. And they end up, one of the streams of new products they're invested in is adhesives.
在不预测未来的情况下，始终做你控制范围之内的事情，事实是，有很多事情是你无法控制的，其中一些确实会打击到你。所以外部世界会给你抛来柠檬。因此，这个想法是，你必须非常擅长应对意料之外的惊喜，然后把甚至可以说是负面的惊喜变成机会。最具标志性的案例就是3M公司，他们一直在创造新产品。最后，他们投资的新产品方向之一就是粘合剂。
And they end up inventing an adhesive that doesn't stick very well. So they usually, it would just go into the trash can as an attempt that failed. And Spence Silver, who was involved in developing the product, is not very happy that it turned out to be a failure until another colleague Art Fry is in, you know, he's in a church choir and he realizes that it would be nice to have something that he can put on his music sheets to mark them but be able to take them off afterwards, right? So he thinks that something like a glue that doesn't stick very well would find use in that. The failure the 3M inventor spent silver experienced, we know it today as the Post-It Note.
结果他们发明了一种粘性不是很好的粘合剂。所以通常情况下，它作为一个失败的尝试会被直接扔进垃圾桶。斯潘塞·西尔弗参与了该产品的研发，他对结果以失败告终并不感到高兴，直到另一位同事阿特·弗瑞参加了唱诗班，他意识到如果在乐谱上贴点东西做标记，用完之后还能轻松揭下来，那就太好了，对吧？所以他认为像这种粘性不是很好的胶水可以在这方面找到用途。3M发明家斯潘塞·西尔弗经历的那次失败，也就是我们今天所熟知的便利贴。
So the lemonade principle is the idea that before you throw stuff away, in fact, most of the time you can make, you know, a lot of good businesses out of trash and then it could become like a very successful product. There is a final principle Saras talks about. Pilots in the plane. Expert entrepreneurs don't merely react to their environment. They actively shape it. They make their own luck, if you will.
所以柠檬汁原则的意思是，在把东西扔掉之前，事实上，大多数时候你可以用废品做出很多好的生意，然后它就能变成一个非常成功的产物。萨拉斯提到的最后一个原则是：飞机上的飞行员。专业创业者不仅仅是对环境做出反应。他们还在积极地塑造环境。可以说，他们在创造自己的运气。
Take a look at Netflix. In the early 2000s, the company's DVD rental-by-mail model was in danger of becoming obsolete. Netflix pivoted to become a streaming service. The company wasn't just trying to win a share of an existing market. They were creating a new market. In so doing, they changed the way we all consume entertainment. They invented their own future. As Saras talked to these entrepreneurs, she found that there was a presiding mindset over all of these principles. Saras calls this mindset, effectuation.
看看奈飞（Netflix）。在2000年代初，该公司通过邮寄租赁DVD的模式正面临被淘汰的危险。奈飞转型成为了一家流媒体服务商。该公司不仅仅是为了赢得现有市场的一份份额。他们正在创造一个新市场。在此过程中，他们改变了我们所有人消费娱乐的方式。他们发明了自己的未来。随着萨拉斯与这些创业者交谈，她发现所有这些原则背后都有一个统领全局的心态。萨拉斯将这种心态称之为：效果逻辑（Effectuation）。
Saras calls this mindset, effectuation. So effectual thinking is a way to minimize predictive information while making decisions under great uncertainty. And the way you minimize predictive information is you're always dividing the world into things within your control and things outside your control. You ignore things outside your control and continuously use things within your control and things outside your control. You ignore things outside your control and continuously use things within your control to shape and co- create the future. That's what effectual thinking is and so you end up creating
萨拉斯将这种心态称之为：效果逻辑。因此，效果逻辑思维是一种在巨大的不确定性下做出决策的同时将预测性信息最小化的方法。而你将预测性信息最小化的方法是，你总是将世界划分为在你控制范围内的事情和不在你控制范围内的事情。你忽略那些不在你控制范围内的事情，并不断利用在你控制范围内的事情，去塑造和共同创造未来。这就是效果逻辑思维，所以你最终会在世界上创造出
new effects in the world, even effects that you did not begin with. I mean in some ways one of the lessons here is that the really successful entrepreneurs have the humility to know that the future is not controllable. And in some ways, once you accept that, then you realize it doesn't make a ton of sense to try and figure out where you're going, try and figure out the destination, try and figure out the big picture strategy.
新的影响，甚至是那些你一开始没有预料到的影响。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，这里的教训之一是，真正成功的创业者具备一种谦逊的态度，深知未来是无法控制的。从某种程度上说，一旦你接受了这一点，你就会意识到，试图去弄清楚你要去哪里、试图找出目的地、试图找出宏观战略，其实并没有多大意义。
All of that, in some ways, is unknowable. Absolutely. You don't have to think, all of that in some ways is unknowable. Absolutely. You don't have to think about all of these other things that people worry about. And then the beauty of it is you actually end up achieving some of those big things precisely because you are not really focusing all your time and attention on it. and attention on it. Saras Sarasvati teaches entrepreneurship at the University of Virginia's Darden School of Business. She's the author of Effectuation, Elements of Entrepreneurial Expertise.
从某种程度上说，所有这一切都是不可知的。绝对是这样。你不需要去想，所有这一切从某种程度上说都是不可知的。绝对是这样。你不需要去思考人们所担心的所有这些其他事情。而它的美妙之处在于，你实际上最终会实现其中一些宏大的事情，恰恰是因为你并没有把所有的时间和精力都集中在它上面。萨拉斯·萨拉斯瓦蒂在弗吉尼亚大学达顿商学院教授创业学。她是《效果逻辑：创业专长的要素》一书的作者。
When we set goals, many of us try to meticulously plan for the future we want, then hope and pray our plan works out. Sometimes it does. Sometimes it doesn't. Saras's research raises an interesting question. What if we took a different approach? Rather than ask what we want from the future, what might happen if we instead asked, what do I have to offer that might change the future? Next week we continue our Innovation 2.0 series with a look at talent. We explore why we're so drawn to people who seem to be naturally gifted
当我们设定目标时，我们许多人试图为我们想要的未来进行细致的规划，然后祈祷我们的计划能实现。有时它会实现。有时则不会。萨拉斯的研究提出了一个有趣的问题。如果我们采取一种不同的方法会怎样？与其实际去问我们对未来有什么期望，如果我们反过来问：我有什么可以奉献的、可能会改变未来的东西？下周我们将继续我们的“创新2.0”系列节目，探讨人才的话题。我们将探讨为什么我们如此被那些似乎具有天赋的人所吸引，
and how our assumptions about talent and hard work can be a barrier to success for both people and organizations. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoyed today's episode, or know a budding entrepreneur who might find it useful, please share it with them. Your word of mouth recommendations are one of the most powerful ways for us to connect
以及我们对人才和努力工作的假设如何成为个人和组织成功的障碍。“隐形大脑”由隐形大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐形大脑”的执行主编。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐形大脑”的执行主编。如果你喜欢今天的节目，或者认识一个可能会觉得它有用的新锐创业者，请分享给他们。你的口碑推荐是将新听众连接到我们在“隐形大脑”中探讨的想法的最有力的方式之一。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》中我们探讨的新观点。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。